paul ronzheimer hat auch viele tage mit
vitali klitschko verbrachte er als held
als bürgermeister von kiew dort gefeiert
wird und wir sind jetzt mit seinem
bruder verbunden sehr schön dass sie
hier bei uns sind es die uns
zugeschaltet sind und sie haben unsere
sendung mitverfolgt wladimir klitschko
sie haben gesehen was die menschen aus
ihrem land berichten sie haben
vielleicht auch mila gesehen die den
westen auffordert helfen sie uns helfen
sie uns die schildert wie ihr bruder
kinder in sicherheit bringt in
u-bahn-schächten was geht ihnen in
diesen stunden in diesen minuten durchs
herz
es ist bis jetzt immer noch eine
anklicken gefasst was gerade passiert
ist ist sehr sehr
blutig und es ist wirklich ein sinnlose
krieg ich verstehe nicht hält wie kam es
in 20 sonst so was was hier was russland
veranstaltet mit den streitkräften
militärfahrzeugen hubschrauber
die truppen auf dem boden und man sieht
man kann ihn davon reden sind das
militär gebete das ist unser land
dabei sterben die zivilisten ich weiß
dass kinder auch gestorben sind weil in
einem krieg stimmt man halt und es gibt
keine guten weg in diesem krieg wird
viel verloren gehe können sie uns
erklären beschreiben was im moment wie
die situation in kiew es können sie das
in diesen stunden ehrlicherweise
überhaupt selbst überblicken
es ist mehr oder weniger unter kontrolle
und
und wir morgens heute
natürlich alle sind mark geboten von
laut explosionen die stadt
und natürlich diskussion ist
die truppen kommen immer näher und
es ist schwer zu beschreiben ist wurde
wo sind sie jetzt gerade herr klitschko
wie sehen ihre nächsten stunden aus das
weiß man nicht
das weiß man nicht wie das video sehr
wird
erstens
karosserie
haben wir haben wir völliges verständnis
weiß nicht ob ich noch weiter fragen
kann wahrscheinlich nicht herr klitschko
mich würde auch interessieren moment in
der in der stadt werden sie dann sich
verstecken müssen im zweifel oder werden
sie selbst zur waffe greifen es gibt
dafür stecken es gibt künftig
werden sie selbst zur waffe greifen ja
meine stadt ja
die mir klitschko uns bleibt leider
nichts mehr als ihnen alles gute zu
wünschen
alles gute flanke ihn
und das sagt uns wladimir klitschko in
einer situation wo wirklich genau in
dieser minute die meldung rein gekommen
ist dass dort in der hauptstadt in kiew
in der er sich gerade irgendwo befindet
dort in einem gebäude da es der
flughafen dort eingenommen worden ist
mittlerweile von russischen truppen
dramatische stunden rund um die
hauptstadt kiew mittlerweile die
hauptstadt der ukraine und mittendrin
ein mann mit wladimir klitschko der
bruder des bürgermeisters dort von kiew
der sagt ja ich werde im zweifel hier
zur waffe greifen